Donald Trump should be feeling
conflicted after all
he'll be entering the White House with a
grab bag of active operations that make
him the most financially entangled
president-elect in modern US history but
Trump says he has a solution to that
problem he's likely to say he's turning
the Trump Organization over to his
eldest son's to run in his absence that
isn't enough however Trump's sons will
still be in regular contact and we can
assume that the boys are going to be
speaking with dad about their business
decisions
Trump's three eldest children are
already members of Trump's transition
team which means they have pivotal roles
helping shape how the West Wing is
staffed and who gets plum appointments
running federal agencies Trump is also
considering appointing his son-in-law
Jared Kushner to a senior White House
role Ivanka Trump who also appears
headed to the White House has sat in on
meetings with japan's Prime Minister
even while a major Japanese Bank backs
her fashion business and back in
Washington the Trump organizations new
hotel has been advising local diplomats
that they'd be smart to do business
there meanwhile Trump himself is staying
on as a producer of the NBC reality TV
show The Celebrity Apprentice meaning
that Trump will be getting paid as
president by one of the country's
largest media companies and all of this
is just the small stuff Trump will soon
have major sway over such things as a
global trade policy federal tax policy
affecting corporations like the Trump
Organization as well as banking
regulations that affect all of the
lenders that the trumps depend on this
isn't the first time that a president's
relatives have bumped up against
concerns about financial conflicts there
have been at least six other scenarios
that warranted reason for alarm about
family members taking advantage of their
proximity to the White House
none of these however approached the
breadth of conflicts that Trump and his
children will carry with them so what
should Trump do he should either sell
everything that he has or he can turn
the Trump Organization over to a truly
independent party other than his
children the Trump Organization is in a
massive fortune 500 corporation it's a
family-run boutique business consisting
of about a dozen golf courses a handful
of hotels some lucrative Manhattan
retail and commercial space a pair of
major real estate investments controlled
by another company and all of those
licensing deals that splash the Trump
name
where it wouldn't be hard to unwind all
of that so come on mr. president-elect
do the right thing it's time to sell or
to find a new business manager
[Music]